pokemon legends arceus shares a lot in
common with a traditional pokemon rpg
serving as a reimagining of many of the
classic series core mechanics but it is
also a radical departure in some ways so
even old pokemon masters may find their
skills don't immediately translate to
this new format pokemon legends arceus
is a prequel to the rest of the series
built around exploring vast open spaces
and capturing monsters by the boatload
as you fill out the hasuy region's first
ever pokedex here are a few things to
know before starting your adventure if
you like this video make sure to give it
a thumbs up and sub to the channel
because we got a lot of pokemon coming
your way alright let's get to it
unlike a traditional pokemon game in
which battling is your main or only path
to leveling up your creatures pokemon
legends arceus is generous with
experience and grants it for all sorts
of things the six pokemon in your party
will get passive experience from
catching wild pokemon even without
battling and from farming crafting
materials simply exploring the world
catching pokemon and smacking trees to
grab apricorns will get you lots of
experience without ever battling a
single pocket monster
rather than evolve when hitting a
certain level milestone your pokemon
will wait for you to initiate the
evolution once they're ready a small
indicator will pop up when they hit the
requisite experience level but then
you'll need to go into the party menu
and select evolve this will start the
evolution your evolved pokemon will have
higher base stats so it will hit harder
and defend better and using it will help
you fill out the pokedex entry for that
next stage of the evolution so if you
ask me the sooner that you are able to
evolve your pokemon the better
the pokeballs in pokemon legends arceus
are somewhat different in part because
the context of catching pokemon is
different there are no quickballs for
example because those are reliant on
when you throw them during a battle
which has been de-emphasized in arceus
however there are still some unique
pokeballs like those that are especially
good at covering long distances like the
feather ball or those that are
especially effective at capturing
pokemon if you catch them by surprise
like the heavy ball
even without a special pokeball stealth
is the best tool in your arsenal for
capturing a pokemon if you sneak up
behind a pokemon it will significantly
increase your chances of capturing it
this is called a back strike and
essentially serves as a critical hit for
your capture chances watch for an
indicator above the pokemon while you're
targeting them to see if they've noticed
your presence if it turns red with an
icon of an eye they have definitely
noticed you and have turned aggressive
so they won't be responsive to any more
pokeballs your only options are to fight
to weaken them for a catch or simply run
away and then circle back if you
successfully pull off a back strike you
will hear a distinct sound that's
different and that sounds a lot heavier
with more oomph than a standard catch
some pokemon and legends arceus hang out
in packs but you don't have to settle
for just one if you fling the pokeballs
fast enough you can capture multiple
pokemon all in a row which will help you
progress toward your pokedex capturing
goals just make sure to act fast because
sometimes pokemon will notice that their
buddies have suddenly vanished and
they'll flee
since pokemon sometimes hang out
together that also means you could find
yourself accidentally caught up in a
multi-battle these can be tricky because
you can still only have one pokemon out
to battle at a time be careful not to
get overwhelmed by too many wild pokemon
at once similarly since powerful alpha
pokemon are given away by their red eyes
and a distinct music change be careful
that you don't try to capture one
without noticing it will attack you and
alphas tend to be above the average
level for any given area
most recent pokemon games have used some
version of a real-time clock meaning
you'd have to play at night to capture
monsters that would only come out at
night pokemon legends arceus doesn't use
a real time clock so days pass on a
regular cycle some pokemon are still
tied to the time of day in game though
so watch for the sun setting to pursue
nocturnal pokemon if you want to fast
forward to the correct time of day or
whatever time that you might need just
go to the nearest base camp and rest in
the tent until the time that you want
much of your exploration involves
catching wild pokemon obviously and
sometimes the tall grass is just a
little too far away from the frolicking
monsters to maintain your hiding spot
while also using the auto aim holding
both triggers usually lines up a shot
but if they're just out of reach you can
manually aim just a tad high usually so
the reticle is just barely touching the
pokemon and it will still hit the target
just fine it might take a little bit of
practice but you'll get the hang of it
soon
like a traditional pokemon game your
monsters will only be able to equip 4
moves at a time but unlike a traditional
pokemon game you can swap learned moves
at will each monster will only learn 4
innate moves by default but then you can
visit a dojo in town to learn more for a
small fee once you teach your pokemon
extra moves you can go into the party
menu to swap which ones are available
for battle if you decide you want to
change back later you can simply swap
again through the party menu without
incurring the additional fee
the battle system in pokemon legends
arceus introduces agile and strong moves
modifiers that you can apply to moves
during battle but only after you've
mastered that move agile is quicker but
weaker sometimes allowing you to attack
twice while strong is slower but
stronger which will sometimes open you
up to double attacks from your opponent
these work in conjunction with the
existing effectiveness ratings so you
can put an agile modifier on a super
effective attack and it will still be
pretty strong against your opponent with
the added benefit of being quick
conversely you could put a strong
modifier on a less effective attack to
help you make up the gap you could also
use an agile move to inflict a status
effect and then immediately follow up
with a regular or strong move or you can
even put a strong spin on a super
effective move to punch a bit above your
weight class you can even get creative
like using agile moves to give you an
advantage in catching pokemon if your
agile move is quick enough you can use
that move and follow up immediately with
a pokeball giving you a better chance of
a successful catch experiment with
different combinations
failing out of a wild battle will start
you at the nearest camp and it will cost
you some of your items and materials so
you should run away whenever those start
to look a bit too hairy story based
battles on the other hand don't really
carry any real risk failing out of those
will simply start you right before the
battle with no penalty and all of your
pokemon actually restore to full health
you can feel free to jump into a story
battle even if your pokemon are a little
banged up from exploring just to get an
idea of what you'll be facing then you
can restart with everyone healed and
ready for action
as you progress through the story you'll
get access to several pokemon mounts
with unique abilities most of these
relate to navigation opening up new
areas those navigation tools are
necessary to proceed to the next story
point but each of the biomes have plenty
of areas that will only be reachable
later once you get the mounts make sure
you go back to older areas you've
already covered and look around for new
areas that you couldn't access before
because there will usually be new
pokemon species and new alphas hiding in
these locations
when you check your map you'll see some
small icons that look like messenger
bags dotted around the landscape these
are satchels bags dropped by other
explorers fetching the satchel is a
simple matter of getting near it and
collecting it like any other farmed item
but the payoff is way more significant
each satchel will get you merit points
usually in the 60 to 70 mp range those
merit points can be traded in town for
goods and that seems to be the only way
to get evolution stones the mp shop is
just off the main village path between
the galaxy team hq and the dojo
the best way to raise your pokemon's
levels is to simply have them out in the
field with you while you complete tasks
but if you're in a bind and need to
quickly raise the level of a particular
pokemon you can always visit the candy
stand just outside the galaxy team hq to
buy experienced candies they can be
rather expensive with the large
experience candy coming in at a whopping
18 000 of the in-game currency but it is
nice to have the option regardless
sprinting in pokemon legends arceus
works very similarly to that of the
legend of zelda breath of the wild with
the ability to run in short bursts but
since increasing your stamina isn't a
central mechanic like it is in zelda
there is no meter that tells you when
your stamina is low from a fully rested
state you can sprint for about eight
seconds after which you'll start to run
at a normal rate if you start to sprint
again before giving yourself enough of a
rest you'll only sprint for a shorter
amount of time
some of your mounts have sprints however
but they're mapped to a face button
instead of the l-stick
alright if you're super curious about
pokemon legends arceus be sure to check
out our video review written by steve
watts we also have gameplay up of the
first several minutes as well as some
wicked cool gameplay showing off space
riffs let me know in the comments how
you feel about the game and if you're
interested in jumping into the world the
hissui region has to offer until next
time
[Music]